samantha and nicolette join us now hello
ladies
okay
i live
for beauty questions i'm obsessed what
is your question
so
i'm a busy mom on the go
how do i make my eyebrows look bolder
but quickly
how bold do you want to go
i mean the bolder the better um all
right well i think we want something
that complements your hair color i think
if you're going to go with a pronounced
brow try to match your hair color and
your question was so i've always
suffered with thin eyebrows so i was
wondering if you could show me how to
quickly make my eyebrows look fuller i
think the same advice for me applies is
just
try to buy any product that matches the
tone of your hair so that it looks as
natural as possible all right so here
i'm gonna take you through let's see
let's open these up
open up your anastasia palettes um so i
am gonna pick the ebony for you i think
it's the closest to your hair color
and for you
i feel like maybe the brunette
um
because
it has a little bit of the grayer tone
and you have some nice like pretty
silver in your hair now what you want to
do is follow the line naturally and if i
see a little hole so start to fill that
in and go light you can always go more
the thing that i love about
this tool is that it actually has this
really nice soft little paddle brush on
the back and it just won allure's best
of beauty for 2021
[Music]
and
that is our company flower beauty
so
when it comes to you i would actually
like to see you pick up the brush
because this is a powder i'd like you to
start with the powder
and
because you're trying to create natural
hairs i would flick it very fine
i am i think your application is
fantastic you clearly know your brows
they're not there so
but you know how to fill them in i know
by your placement you're doing such a
good job thank you
oh you are doing so well you need no
advice at all
now in this
one area right here do a little of the
paddle brush and sort of take it off and
go back and forth like a seahawk yes and
just keep brushing as you're going
yeah you got that face going uh-huh
you know you're in the zone when you
have that face
i like it
i think you guys are doing such a great
job you guys keep working on this we've
got one more question and this one's
from ashley let's check it out
hi drew i love my dark brown hair but
i'm ready for a drastic change how do i
ease into it but still get a different
look
all right well celebrity hair stylist
and dear friend of our show
and me um chris appleton has the answer
chris what are your tips to easy
changing of the color without bleach
damage drama the tips i always have for
changing your hair color is first of all
making sure that you look at the most
important things which is your skin tone
your eye colour and also even your
personality type and ashley took your
advice she did and here's what ashley
looked like before
okay well this is what ashley looks like
now i'm very excited ashley
ashley
[Applause]
i really love it now ashley give a
little slow turn is the light picking
that up
chris i love this so as you guys can see
i'm going to just put your head to the
side so basically this is kind of where
we lighten most of the colour so she
wanted to keep her kind of natural base
so she didn't get problems with you know
regrowth but lighting out the ends and
this is just a starting point into going
to into something lighter and it's
actually you know you you found that
quite dramatic just kind of adding that
lightness to you
how do you feel ashley i love it i think
it's great it looks like a high
maintenance haircut but it's really not
and it's fantastic it makes me feel
great i'm looking forward to working it
[Applause]
thank you so much
i mean there's something in your
attitude i feel like you have a major
bounce right i do i got it going on you
think
i got my swagger bag
[Applause]
i feel it
photographic evidence right here you
look like a different person well cheers
to that
all right ashley i can't wait to see
your final look with your new wardrobe
and your gorgeous hair and most of all
what you are putting out there
[Music]